is veterans day and on this veterans day
president-elect joe biden and his team
are planning the tradition
transition rather to the white house
however resistance from the trump
administration is not making the process
easy
the president still has not accepted the
election results skyler henry is at the
white house with more
president trump commemorated veterans
day laying a wreath at the tomb of the
unknown soldier
while president-elect joe biden to
timeout from working on the transition
to attend a ceremony in philadelphia
in their memory and all those others who
did not come home
president trump is still not recognizing
mr biden as the president-elect
the trump campaign has filed a new
lawsuit in michigan
with 234 pages of affidavits claiming
voting irregularities
and georgia's secretary of state
announced a full hand recount
of every vote to ensure the validity of
the results
this will help build confidence it will
be an audit
a recount and a re-canvas all at once
president trump's refusal to accept the
outcome of the election means
president-elect joe biden
is not receiving daily intelligence
briefings incoming presidents typically
receive
access to classified information is uh
is useful but i'm not a position to make
any decisions
on those issues anyway there's one as i
said one president at a time
mr biden received calls from world
leaders tuesday
including british prime minister boris
johnson german chancellor angela merkel
and french president emmanuel macron i'm
ready to congratulate you
however cbs news has confirmed the state
department is not
assisting with those calls and secretary
of state mike pompeo suggested tuesday
there may not be a biden administration
there will be a smooth transition to a
second trump administration
president-elect biden said republicans
will eventually accept his presidency
skyler henry cbs news the white house